I'm so proud to be here tonight
representing the David and Helen Gurley
Brown Institute for media innovation and
I'm grateful to Lee Bollinger Steve call
Frank been achieve Burton my colleague
behringer road for being here
celebrating with us and thank you all
for being with us this is really a
paradigm the best example I can think of
what a great university does we have a
great professional School in journalism
a great under graduate and professional
School in engineering each of them see
things in the world that are changing
and require a great University to be
responsive it's a real milestone that
that we have reached the space here at
the journalism school is really meant to
be the epicenter of the Institute's and
you see how much excitement there is in
the group of brown fellows and magic
grant recipients who are here today and
then many friends that the institute has
here in the in the community and of
course also at the west coast the whole
idea of a media center is incredible
it's so 23rd century that I think it
would absolutely stunned not David who
was somebody who believed firmly and
changed and we should get very angry at
me saying what do you mean you don't
believe in chain he loved change Helen
liked it as long as she didn't have to
get too involved with it but she would
have learned as much as she could and I
think she would have been incredibly
proud journalism and Technology are now
in extra blue lake in an academic
setting thanks to Ellen and David Brown
and two great universities this gift is
not only her vibrant vision of public
service it was personal to her she knew
that many talented
who had emerged to make the media world
a better place and if only they had the
opportunity and support to back them
which he provided she knew because that
was her story the David and Helen Gurley
Brown Institute for media innovation is
her commitment to paying it forward the
brown Institute's support is inspiring
teams already to break convention and
think big at a time when in journalism
we really need that and specifically
we're working with new platforms to try
to adapt consume uter science to renew
journalism and at least for our part in
the project that's at the heart of our
ambition something amazing has already
happened here the boundaries are down
and collaboration is in vogue next
generation ideas have already emerged
and begun to take form they are
beautiful they are functional they are
compelling and in or their magical over
the next days and months in probably
years we'll learn how to you to make use
of this space helping the School of
Journalism become V place for media
innovation so with that
lovely leopard